[Music]
[Applause]
in 1971 a guy named daniel ellsberg
leaked what would become known as the
pentagon papers
papers that expose just how bad
america's military action in vietnam was
the pentagon papers were a revelation it
exposed that the government
systematically lied not only to the
public but also to congress end quote
and president nixon was not happy about
the leak
this is a devastating uh
security breach
you mean that that was leaked out of the
pentagon well now i just start right at
the top and fire some people i mean
whoever whatever department it came out
about fire the top guy
the guy that leaked at daniel ellsberg
had to be destroyed
and i'm not kidding nixon literally told
us aids that they needed to quote
destroy that son of a and i don't care
how you do it quote you can't let the
jew steal that stuff and get away with
the end quotes
we've got to keep our eye on the main
ball the main ball is ellsberg we gotta
get this son
so daniel ellsberg was charged with
conspiracy espionage and theft of
government property with a possible
sentence of 115 years
but it didn't stop there
next up nixon improved the creation of a
special investigations unit nicknamed
the plumbers
the job of the plumbers to fix leaks of
course so ex-cia and fbi agents broke
into ellsberg's psychiatrist's office to
look for damning information they could
use to assassinate his character
they found nothing
they then proceeded to wiretap him
without warrant and the cia conducted
psychological profiles on him
you were concerned because the action
was known to you to be illegal
it was only after the watergate scandal
and the investigation that followed that
prosecutors discovered this illegal
campaign against the leaker and the
charges were dropped
but the lesson from this was clear
expose the dirty actions of the
government and they will stop at nothing
to ruin your life
38 years later one man would choose not
to pay attention to this lesson this man
would become inspired by daniel illsberg
and his leaking of the pentagon papers
and this man went by the name of julian
assange
in 2006 julian assange would pick up the
mantle daniel ellsberg left behind and
create wikileaks
and for the past 10 years the us
government has been trying their
damnedest to get their hands on assaj to
teach him that same lesson but to no
avail but it looks like their
opportunity has finally come
let me bring you some breaking news the
london court has ruled that wikileaks
founder julian assange can be extradited
to the united states
julian assange is probably going to get
extradited to the us this year to stand
trial for espionage and if he does he is
as good as dead either from dying in
prison or by meeting the same fate meant
by others who had too much dirt on those
in power
[Music]
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime on my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
we're picking a random person who
follows me on instagram every week to
win all you have to do is follow me at
jaketrain and you're automatically
entered watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
and this is the execution of julian
assange
[Music]
julian assange had to take his online
security extremely seriously for obvious
reasons but contrary to popular belief
online security is not just for at-risk
people like asajj the internet pervades
every aspect of our lives and if you get
compromised online you could get your
identity stolen like someone does every
14 seconds they could ruin your credit
score you could get your money stolen
your crypto stolen your instagram could
be hacked like i'm sure has happened to
some of you guys or your friends you
could set back your life by years all
because of a simple cyber crime and
guess what all of these cyber crimes are
just getting more and more popular so
it's not a matter of if you'll be a
victim but when the problem is
protecting yourself online used to mean
paying for a ton of different apps like
a vpn identity theft protection a
password manager fraud monitoring
anti-virus software and all of a sudden
you're paying like 50 a month for all
these different services which not many
people can afford if only there was an
app that combined all these important
services into an all-in-one affordable
app well you're in luck because that's
where aura comes in today's video
sponsor what's really cool and scary is
that right when i sign up for aura i
discovered that my information was
leaked on the dark web six different
times so i think this feature alone is
definitely worth signing up for their 14
day free trial just to make sure you
don't have any sensitive data like that
floating around on the dark web but
there's a lot more you can then use aura
to monitor your bank accounts for
suspicious transactions you can monitor
and lock your credit score right within
the app locking your credit score is
usually a very tedious thing to do but
this makes it super easy which i really
like you can download their anti-virus
software to run scans on your computer
every day automatically which is what i
do and whenever or detect something
suspicious like a virus on your computer
they'll send you a text right to your
phone they have 24 7 customer support
every single day of the year and they
even offer a 60 day money back guarantee
and right now if you go to aura.com jake
with the link below you'll get two weeks
of aura for free so pause the video and
go to aura.com with the link below to
get two weeks free and thanks to aura
for sponsoring this video
for the past 10 years assange has been
running hiding and fighting for his life
all because he published secret
government information on a public
website but the strange thing is he
didn't leak the information himself he
didn't hack into any computers himself
all he did was publish hidden
information given to him by somebody
else something that journalists do every
single day and yet the us government
wants him to spend the rest of his life
in jail or even worse
assange wanted to build a website where
people could anonymously send their
leaks and be sure they were quickly
going to be made public basically
wikileaks was going to be a tip line for
any secrets people believe the public
should know you could send in your
information the raw data pictures and
documents you wanted to leak assange and
his team would then analyze it and if
they thought it was important enough for
the public to see they would send it on
to newspapers online journals and they
would sometimes post it themselves at
least that was the plan in assange's
mind there was no way he could get into
trouble for doing this
thousands of journalists around the
world published secret information they
got from their sources every day why
would wikileaks be treated any
differently and for the first four years
of its existence assange was kinda right
wikileaks published information from all
over the world documents proving a
former kenyan president was corrupt
alleged criminal activity by a swiss
bank in the cayman islands they even
went up against scientology but none of
these leaks really got them on the radar
they were interesting sure but they
weren't targeting powerful enough people
but in 2010 that all changed
us army intelligence analyst chelsea
manning sent wikileaks nearly half a
million documents she downloaded from
the army databases much like the
pentagon papers of the vietnam war these
documents revealed the reality of the
war in iraq and it was much worse how
iraqi soldiers were executing and
torturing entire families while the
americans did nothing to stop them how a
u.s apache helicopter gunned down enemy
soldiers who were surrendering and how
the number of civilians killed in iraq
was actually 60 000 people far higher
than the u.s wanted to admit
julian assange had made the same fatal
mistake daniel ellsberg of the pentagon
papers made decades ago and now he was
going to pay the price
how dare assange an australian publish
information that makes america look bad
that was the general consensus from the
obama administration
the united states strongly condemns the
illegal disclosure
of classified information
it puts people's lives in danger
threatens our national security
and undermines our efforts to work with
other countries
to solve shared problems assange had
made his first real enemy but soon he
was going to have a whole lot more to
deal with
[Music]
we publish cia reports all the time that
are legitimate cia reports that doesn't
mean
the cia is telling the truth
this morning after nearly seven years
inside the ecuadorian embassy mr assange
was arrested for failing to surrender in
relation to his extradition proceedings
in 2010 julian assange is accused of
raping a woman in sweden even though he
hasn't officially been charged by sweden
he is arrested by uk police in assange's
mind it was obvious who was behind this
america they want him to travel to
sweden so they can extradite him to
america so as soon as the order is given
for his extradition to sweden he runs he
flees to the ecuadorian embassy in
london where the ambassador grants him
asylum and that's where things start to
go downhill for assange he literally
lives in a tiny apartment in the middle
of the embassy he has a bedroom a little
kitchen and he even teaches himself to
skateboard as he spends the next seven
years of his life in this tiny apartment
to avoid rest
but even this couldn't stop him from
publishing even more leaks from 2012 to
2019 julian assange manages to anger
every major political party in america
as well as the embassy he was staying at
he publishes democratic national
committee emails he got from a russian
agent he posts a leak of the cia's
entire collection of super secret
hacking tools annoying donald trump
enough to lie and say he knows nothing
about wikileaks wikileaks i love
wikileaks these wikileaks wikileaks
wikileaks as confirmed just today by
wikileaks it's been amazing what's
coming out on wikileaks they want to
distract us from wikileaks the wonder of
wikileaks
well that wikileaks has done a job on
her has it
i know nothing about wikileaks and then
he takes on the new ecuadorian president
and that was really the last straw you
see the new president of ecuador had
actually been the target of some of
wikileaks posts and he was not exactly
happy keeping assange safe from
america's wrath so the ecuadorians
decide it's time to cut him loose
on april 11 2019 the embassy invites the
uk police inside to arrest julian
assange jailed in belmarsh prison for
skipping bail and waiting for the u.s to
request his extradition assange was now
facing the fight of his life while he
was in the embassy the u.s had secretly
indicted him on 18 charges if they
managed to get this extradition approved
his life would be over so he did
everything he could possibly think of to
avoid extradition he appealed over and
over again he married the mother of his
children who was a uk citizen while
still in jail hoping that would give the
judge a reason to keep him in england he
even pointed out how the swedish rape
accusations against him had been dropped
there was no reason for the uk to keep
him in prison america had used its
influence to stack all the cards against
him and in april 2022 after spending
more than two years in jail julian
assange was approved to be extradited to
america
julian assange is now staring death in
the face for doing something every major
news organization in the world does
every single day
[Music]
2018 a year before assange is arrested
in london the u.s justice department
filed secret criminal charges against
him for his role in wikileaks
so when assange was arrested a year
later he wasn't just facing bail
skipping charges oh no he was facing the
full wrath of the american government
you see in america's eyes assange hadn't
just done what any good journalist would
do in published leaks
no he had asked for the leaks and he had
used them to embarrass america to share
its secrets with the world and make its
intelligence agencies look totally
incompetent this wasn't america going
after a criminal this time it was
personal but what exactly was in the 18
charge indictment filed against assange
the first charge is probably the least
of assange's problems it basically
accuses assange of conspiring to commit
computer intrusion which means the us
has proof assange planned on hacking
into one of their networks luckily for
assange he never actually did any
hacking so his maximum sentence for the
charge would be five years but that's
where the minor charges end you see all
17 of the other charges against assange
are based on the espionage act the
espionage act was created in 1917 during
world war one and basically it was
supposed to punish anyone in the
military with access to important or
secret information from sharing it with
the enemy
chelsea manning was charged according to
the espionage act because she had been a
member of the military and leaked the
documents herself that made sense but
according to the american government by
publishing and aiding people to leak
government secrets to the public julian
assange was violating the espionage act
too but here's the thing assange isn't a
soldier or an intelligence officer he
doesn't have any security clearance he's
not even american so how does any of
this apply to him
and that's after ignoring the elephant
in the room the fact that assange never
actually leaked or stole any information
himself
if assange is extradited to the u.s he
could face 10 years in jail for every
charge of violating the espionage act
that's 170 years excluding the sentence
he could receive for the attempted
hacking charge chelsea manning the army
analyst who stole and leaked nearly 750
000 secret army documents was sentenced
to 35 years in jail after almost seven
years in prison her sentence was
commuted and she was released
how could a member of the army who
admitted to stealing hundreds of
thousands of documents get 35 years in
jail while the guy who published those
leaks just published them could be
facing certain death and what about all
the newspapers and magazines that wrote
stories on those leaks would they be
facing criminal charges too
[Music]
today assange isn't the young fired up
activist he once was before after seven
years locked in a tiny room seven years
of doing everything he can to avoid
arrest seven years of always looking
over his shoulder assange's mental
health has taken a turn for the worse
for the longest time assange didn't even
know what the charges against him would
be for all he knew he could be faced
with a death sentence and that sort of
pressure takes a toll on you and then
going from the isolation of the embassy
to the cold unfriendly environment of a
maximum security prison just made
everything worse
in may 2019 doctors who assessed assange
said he showed clear signs of
psychological torture mr assange showed
all the symptoms that are typical for
persons that have been exposed to
prolonged psychological torture in other
words julian assange had reached his
breaking point if the extradition goes
ahead and assange gets taken to america
to stand trial one of three things will
probably happen
faced with all the trauma of the past 10
years and the prospect of spending the
rest of his life in jail julian assange
might kill himself or like our guy every
jepstein assange might be the victim of
a quote assisted suicide the standard
punishment for having too much dirt on
powerful people and if assange doesn't
kill himself or get killed within the
first few months he'll spend the last
years of his life rotting in a
guantanamo style maximum security prison
no matter which path he takes
extraditing julian assange to america is
as good as a death sentence
from there the espionage act would reach
its final form the ultimate open-ended
act that would allow the us government
to silence any journalist
around the same time america was dealing
with the fallout from the manning leaks
they had also found a stash of secret
information themselves may 2nd 2011 seal
team 6 successfully locates and kills
osama bin laden the most wanted
terrorist in the world but as soon as
the team goes through his compound in
pakistan they discover something
unexpected a treasure trove of computers
hard drives nooks letters notebooks and
printed files lying around on every
floor
these files could contain priceless
intelligence and if they left it for the
pakistani military to collect they may
never get their hands on it again so
under the cover of darkness the seals
radio back to their commanders asking
for time they're given 10 more minutes
in hostile territory those 10 minutes
turn into 18 and as a result seal team 6
brings home nearly 500 000 physical and
digital files now known as the bin laden
papers for years most of those documents
were kept classified hidden from the
public but in 2017 the cia finally
declassified 470 thousand and what they
contained was a complete revelation
these files showed a whole new side of
osama bin laden that the world had never
seen before but here's the thing youtube
is smart and runs image recognition
algorithms over every video posted to
look for things that aren't ad friendly
and videos and images of bin laden and
911 definitely trigger it right away so
this video would get demonetized
instantly which is why we just released
it as a brand new private documentary
available only to members of this
channel the video goes over every detail
of the bin laden papers and all of their
infamy and channel members have been
loving this documentary all you have to
do to get access to this documentary
right now and all the other documentary
length videos that are too controversial
too dark too risky to post publicly is
to click the join button below once you
sign up you'll get exclusive access to
the bin laden papers plus others like
every epstein monsanto the company that
owns the world's food supply mk ultra
and many more in the future these are
the things they should be teaching you
in university about how the world works
but unlike university you get all of
this for just five dollars a month and
what's even better is that if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
me and we'll personally refund you the
money pause the video and click that
join button below right now
this is a story that we're going to be
following really closely so if there are
any major developments we'll probably
make another video on it so if you're
new here my name is shake and this is
one of the biggest channels for
documentaries on money power war and
crime and we make multiple videos just
like this every single week for free so
click the subscribe button below don't
forget to get that two-week free trial
of oro with the link below it's a great
app that i like using and if you want a
chance to win a thousand dollars follow
me on instagram jake tran watch out for
fake accounts that's gonna wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
you